something that's boring goes nowhere it
travels in a circle
it never arrives at its destination
the repetitive nature of the shadow life
and of addiction
is what makes both so tedious no
traction is ever gained
no progress is made we're stuck in the
same endlessly repeating loop
that's what makes addiction like hell
all addictions share among others two
primary qualities
one they embody repetition without
progress
two they produce incapacity as a payoff
remember my friend who is addicted to
love she's charming
she's interesting she's beautiful and
adventurous and intelligent
if you saw a story about her in vanity
fair you might think
wow what a brilliant life this woman
leads full of drama and romance and
glamour
i wish i had that life i love my friend
but she has wasted her life
i know because i've wasted vast tracts
of my own
my friend has used the pursuit of love
to produce incapacity
and it has worked for her for decades
her multiple talents have gone
unexplored untried and unrealized
she has become a version of herself but
it is a shadow version
an inverted version a crippled version
she is miserable and she cannot or will
not change
you might disagree with me you might say
my friend has a great life
you might be right distraction
and displacement seem innocent on the
surface how can we be harming ourselves
by having fun or seeking romance
or enjoying the fruits of this big
beautiful world
but lives go down the tubes one
repetition at a time
one deflection at a time 140 characters
at a time
the following is a sampling in no
particular order
of garden variety addictions that fall
short of hardcore chemical dependency
but are still more than potent enough to
[ __ ] malformed
and destroy our lives
23 addicted to failure
there's a difference between failing
which is a natural and normal part of
life
and being addicted to failure when we're
addicted to failure
we enjoy it each time we fail we are
secretly relieved
there's a glamour to failure that has
been mined for centuries by starving
poets
romantic suicides and other self-defined
doomed souls
this glamour inverts failure and turns
it into quote-unquote
success i've had a romance with this
goddess myself
have you the lure of failure can be as
intoxicating as the hardest of hardcore
narcotics
its payoff is incapacity when we fail we
are off the hook
we have given ourselves a get out of
jail free card
we no longer have to ask and answer
stanislavski's famous three questions
who am i why am i here
what do i want
24 addicted to sex
if addictions and shadow careers are
metaphors
sex is the richest one of all and the
most difficult to decode
why are we obsessed with sex do sex
represent conquest
or surrender are we seeking the oblivion
of orgasm
or the transcendence of escaping the ego
is union with another our goal or are we
seeking to dominate or humiliate our
partner
is sex about love are we seeking a soul
mate a mother slash
father are we trying to reach god
i don't see what all the fuss about sex
is said the comedian
it's only friction my own theory
is that the obsessive pursuit of sex is
an attempt to obliterate the ego
i.e normal consciousness the monkey mind
that tortures us with restlessness
fear anger and self-centeredness
we're trying to get to the level above
that
the entity we're seeking union with is
ourselves
we're trying to connect with our true
being our soul
ourself
25 addicted to distraction
resistance hates two qualities above all
others
concentration and depth why
because when we work with focus and we
work deep
we succeed how did tom brady master the
art of the forward pass
how did picasso paint how did yo-yo ma
learn the cello
resistance wants to keep us shallow and
unfocused
so it makes the superficial and the vein
intoxicating
have you checked your email in the last
half hour
when you sit down to do your work do you
leave your web connection
on it can be fatal keeping up with the
kardashians
26 addicted to money
the real utility of money is its
convenience as a medium of exchange
if you and i have a goat and smyrna we
don't have to carry the poor beast in
our arms all the way to aleppo to trade
it for a carpet
we can sell the goat in smyrna stash of
silver derrick in our pocket
and take the derrick to aleppo to buy
the carpet but when we're addicted to
money
we become hooked on the metaphor is
money how we keep score
is it magic is wealth a currency that
opens doors realizes
possibilities produces transcendence
money is second only to sex and the
richness of its metaphor
but as in the case of carnality our real
object
is the currency of our own hearts the
same premise applies to power
fame and all other external expressions
of potency
what you and i are really seeking is our
own voice
our own truth our own authenticity
27 addicted to trouble
there are more than 2 million people
behind bars in the united states
and another 5 million on probation or
parole
how many millions more are
self-imprisoned in cycles of abuse
of others or of themselves or habituated
other forms of vice
corruption and depravity why is trouble
so intoxicating
because its payoff is incapacity
the scars and tattoos of the convict are
his shadow symphony
his displaced epic his unpainted
masterpiece
the individual addicted to trouble will
never get out of jail
because he is safer behind bars than
free out in the world
each time he is released he will find a
way to get sent back
the payoff for the prisoner is released
from the agonizing imperative
of identifying embracing and bringing
into material existence
the dreams and visions of his own
deepest
noblest and most honorable heart